that's right 24 pages it's drawn up by a
committee of seven MPS four of which Sam
are conservative so as Boris Johnson
basically alleges that what you're
reading today is not fair and balanced
bear that uh point in mind uh and it
comes with a huge amount of evidence a
detailed work by MPS on the committee
and basically comes up with a series of
points that they're going to put to
Boris Johnson when he appears before the
committee is somewhere around three
weeks obviously Boris Johnson an MP he
was effectively dragged from Office
always going to be explosive this issue
and so this report has proved let's
start by looking here at one of the key
conclusions that the report has come to
they find that there is an evidence that
a culture of drinking in the workplace
in some parts of number 10 continued
after those covid restrictions began and
the events such as birthday parties and
leaving parties for officials continued
in number 10 despite workplace guidance
on social distance sing the report talks
about the extensive evidence that it
collected not just WhatsApp we'll get
onto that in a moment but quite clearly
these seven MPS conducted a site visit
to number 10 they actually went to
number 10 a couple of weeks ago and uh
one of their key pieces of evidence for
challenging Boris Johnson which they're
going to do is that they actually looked
at just how easy it was to see what was
going on in the parties in the Press
office from Boris Johnson's basically
the entrance to Boris Johnson's private
flat uh because they said that from the
bottom of the stairs leading up to what
was Mr then Mr Johnson's flat into the
Press office vegetable uh there was a uh
what basically a line of sight so let's
look at the meat of this report uh first
of all and here we have uh perhaps the
most important uh uh sentence that Mr uh
that Boris Johnson will have to Grapple
with when he appears before the
committee there is evidence that the
House of Commons may have been misled in
the following ways which the committee
will applaud see that's what their
trying to investigate whether or not
Boris Johnson lied at the dispatch box
not re-litigating large parts of whether
there are parties or not the police and
to a certain extent Sue gray have done
that already it's whether or not Boris
Johnson lies and this report comes up
with four four different ways in which
they think Boris Johnson may have lied
and they'll be asking him about that in
about three weeks MPS may have been
misled when Mr Johnson said on the 8th
of December 2021 that no rules or
guidance had been broken in number 10.
so that was a key moment in Parliament
where Boris Johnson uh uh basically said
no rules have been broken obviously the
police took a different conclusion and
that effectively what the MPS are basing
there at judgment on second reason it
may have been misled when Mr Johnson
failed to tell the house about his own
knowledge of gatherings where the rules
or guidance had been broken that is
because there is evidence that he
attended them so again MPS suggesting
that Boris Johnson really should have
known better when he talked to uh when
he addressed MPS in the House of Commons
at the dispatch box because he was at
some of the events third thing they're
going to ask Boris Johnson about it may
have been miss commas may have been
misled when Mr Johnson said on the uh
December the 8th that he relied upon
repeated assurances uh that the rules
had not been broken uh and actually the
committee go through in some detail uh
why they think that actually just
relying on assurances who was giving the
assurances and the basis for the
assurances was simply not good enough in
their View for the government to
basically formulate a line to the
outside world that nothing had been
going on uh and uh fourth the fourth
reason
uh that uh MPS suspect that the house
comes might have been misled uh is
because Mr Johnson gave the impression
that there needed to be investigation by
the second permanent secretary to
establish whether the rules and guidance
had been broken before he could answer
questions uh to the house uh while
repeatedly making statements to the
house uh he appears to have had personal
knowledge that he has did not reveal in
other words MPS are saying why is Boris
Johnson basically saying he needs an
independent inquiry where he could have
answered immediately at quite a lot of
the questions uh the MPS were asking but
the whatsapps are absolutely key to this
and when you look at very senior figures
you see all the way along they have been
quite uncertain about what to do in the
face of public denials the director of
communications at the time was saying
things like I don't know what we say
about the flat please can we say uh
something uh very robust uh and um uh
other uh let me just come into the next
one you have other whatsapps uh where
number 10 say that they're worried about
leaks of the Prime Minister having a
piss up and to be fair I don't think
that's unwarranted so deep concern about
all of this in number 10 you do have
lots of pictures in this including this
one of a gathering which was in November
2020 but just look at that I'll leave
you with that that's the table where uh
the uh uh the table at the heart of the
Gathering you can see one two three four
five bottles of wine what maybe a bottle
of vodka clearly alcohol colored liquid
in the various plastic cups a little bit
of takeaway number 10 Boris Johnson will
still have to maintain that wasn't an
illegal gathering at the height of the
pandemic we look forward to hearing from
him in about three weeks